durant l'épidémie de kovy de 19 la
france a été confrontée à une pénurie de
matériel de protection
et il ne s'agit pas là seulement des
masques toutes sortes d'équipements ont
manqué aux hôpitaux au sein de l'hôpital
cochin un nouveau laboratoire
d'imprimantes 3d exceptionnelle a vu le
jour au mois de mars
il a produit durant l'épidémie quarante
mille pièces pour les hôpitaux et les
soignants une création imaginée par le
chirurgien parisien
romane ausein khonsari en collaboration
avec l'université de médecine paris
descartes
ça a été très rapide de monter sa
structure nous avons présenté le projet
la direction de l'assistance publique
donc là monsieur martin hirsch le
directeur général il a donné son accord
de principe
une idée réalisable également grâce au
financement du groupe kering ce centre
est devenu le plus grand centre mondial
d'impression 3d au sein d'un hôpital et
il se trouve dans un lieu très
particulier
ici c'est la salle principale de la
plate forme 3d port royal qui faisait
partie de l'abbaye royale c'est là on a
le plus grand nombre de nos machines
menace 60 ans tout la technologie de ces
machines là c'est la même
c'est une technologie par dépôt de fil
mais chacune de ces machines à des
spécificités techniques qui lui
permettent de produire des pièces de
tailles différentes avec des matériaux
différents
ça va de dispositifs médicaux qui sont
par exemple ici des connecteurs pour des
appareils de respiration en réanimation
des masques de ventilation jusqu'à des
dispositifs de maintenance puis en
produit également des dispositifs de
protection vous voyez ici les visières
clouté beaucoup utilisé dans l'endurance
pic de la crise du coc vide alors
comment ça marche des ingénieurs
modélise l'élément demander ou encore le
scan grâce à des appareils très
sophistiqués réalisé par les ingénieurs
russes de la société luxembourgeoise
artec 3d un logiciel envoie ensuite la
commande aux imprimantes qui peuvent la
répliquer par milliers d'exemplaires
qu'est ce que c'est la pièce qui a été
un plus mais un support cardiologie
s'agira tenir libyenne
c'est un support mural aujourd'hui
quelque chose qui n'existait pas et
qu'on a créé haddock en fait pour le
service n'aura une pièce qui sera
vraiment fonctionnel assez rapidement en
deux trois heures sera réglé au plus
fort de la crise il y avait plusieurs
milliers de pièces qui était produit
tous les jours en fait des pièces qui
étaient essentiellement des dispositifs
de protection des prototypes pour des
dispositifs médicaux ont été barrés tout
juste un petit peu l'innovation et puis
maintenant il y en a maintenant c'est
l'inversé beaucoup plus de pièces en
l'innovation et puis pour le maintien de
toutes les pièces toute la maintenance
de l'hôpital qui sont produites en
permanence ce projet innovant qui va
bientôt déménager dans un autre site
parisien intéresse déjà à
l'international il pourrait se décliner
dans les années à venir dans des zones
de guerre est là où apparaissent de
nouvelles épidémies